today we're going to be speaking with
mark tuschnet who is emeritus professor
at harvard law school and also a
specialist in u.s
and comparative constitutional law uh
it's so great to have you on i really
appreciate it
thanks for having me so i guess to get
into this conversation
there's been significant debate over the
last few months since the passing of
supreme court justice ruth bader
ginsburg
about the correct number of supreme
court justices and questions like
whether there should for example be a
term limits for supreme court justices
but
there's another approach and that's one
of questioning whether
we really even need or or should have a
supreme court so i mean let's let's just
start there
what do you believe the purpose of the
supreme court
was originally and does it still fulfill
that purpose
well the basic idea of the court was
that you needed some body
that would be able to enforce
the provision of the constitution
you could expect politicians to debate
the constitutional issues and
reach compromises and so on and so
politics might be one way of making sure
that
uh people adhere to the constitution but
early on people started worrying that
politicians might find it in their
mutual interest to do something that was
inconsistent with the constitution
to agree on oh
some program that gave the president too
much power
sure or more likely that we
of what we think of today uh enact
programs that violated individual rights
and the thought was you could insert a
court
into the process so as to
to check against those possibilities
and at this point in time is that
number one still necessary and number
two
is that the primary activity that the
supreme court is engaged in
checking that well on the second
question no actually it turns out not
the primary thing the court does
things that don't get as much attention
is interpret statutes uh tell
you know congress passes a statute it's
got some provisions in it that aren't
clear uh and and the supreme court
comes up with an authoritative
interpretation of the statute
um on the first um
i think it's it's a tricky question
about
whether the court is um
now either needed or doing too much
in terms of enforcing
constitutional provisions the reason
it's tricky
is that we now understand that there's
a lot of that would put it this way
reasonable disagreement
about what the constitution actually
means um
and it's everybody thinks
they know uh
the constitution prohibits things that
they don't like
happening but it turns out that
it's very difficult to say
that very often legislators or
congress president actually do things
that
nobody could fairly say are
consistent with the constitution
occasionally they do
once in a while but most of the time
what the court's doing
is saying you have this interpretation
of the constitution
maybe it's a reasonable one but we have
a different one
and we're going to stop you from doing
what
you think is consistent with the
constitution
so in terms of uh yeah no prof so in
term in terms of if there were no
supreme court
is it is it as simple as the
the the next lowest court's decision
it becomes the final decision is it that
simple or is there more rearranging that
would need to be done
well you'd probably want to do more
rearranging i mean
what if it were if you just took the
court out of the process entirely
then you'd end up with the possibility
of
a court in california saying something
constitutionally okay
and a court in massachusetts saying it's
not okay
yeah that's not impossible i mean you
can live with a world like that
but it's sort of awkward we think it's
our constitution
um so you probably if you take the court
out of the process you probably
want to uh take the lower courts out of
it as well
and how would you do that would you
establish some kind of a
well i mean i won't i won't even pretend
to know how you would do it how would it
be done what would what would be the way
that you would rearrange that process
well my preferred solution would be to
say yes we can
still keep the courts involved uh for
reasons that i'll get to in just a
moment
but they should apply a standard
we could even write it into the
constitution that they should hold
things
unconstitutional only if they are my
phrase is
manifestly unreasonable uh
and and that sharply reduces the uh
degree to which the courts any court
could uh could intervene
in in constitutional interpretation it
would still give them some role
but only for extreme cases
in terms of the more common reforms that
are sometimes mentioned or
changes to the court things like
changes to the process by which
by the mere chance or timing
of who is president at the time that a
vacancy is created
changing that so it's not just the the
whim of whether there's a republican or
a democrat in the white house
changing the number of justices on the
court putting term limits
for being on the court do you do you
like any of these
all of them none of them um
so i'm in favor of sort of any program
that's
likely to have some effect on reducing
the role of the court in our political
life
okay uh people the most popular thing
the
of the things you've mentioned are term
limits
and um i'm i've signed on to a term
limits proposal
um people who favor them do think that
if you have sort of a regular process of
arrival and departure then
the stakes for each appointment
will go down and that might lower
the uh willingness of the court to get
involved in deep
uh political matters the appointment
process would be more routine less
highly politicized
um i think that might happen um
the the the expanding the size of the
court which is also something i
currently
favor uh um would
temporarily actually make the court more
prominent
uh because people would focus on on
well they've just you know expanded the
court
to change the rulings that are coming
out of it
but people also seem to think that
eventually
there'd be some sort of uh equilibrium
where first democrats expand the court
then republicans expand
the court and eventually people come to
understand that that's not
a terrible terribly great way of doing
things
and what you really want to do is again
lower the temperature of the court's
activity
and so you know they people talk about
reducing the legitimacy of the court i
think that's basically a good thing
uh and so if court expansion had that
effect
that would be okay with me too when it
comes to
um the idea of uh and i know that
this is sort of a different different
question the idea of constitutional
originalism which is a very very big
debate
to me there's a few elements that that
sort of don't pass the sniff test
that are very often mentioned and i'm
curious to get your thoughts on it one
is
if we're talking about constitutional
originalism
as thought at the time of the
constitution's creation when we talk
about bearing
arms we would have to account for the
types of arms that existed at the time
and recognize a lot of what's available
today
would be out of scope even even
theoretically imaginable at the time
when you talk about cruel and unusual
punishment what we have today is is
dramatically different than what would
have
fallen under that definition at the time
so how
what is your sense in terms of this
debate around originalism
which is often put forward by those who
seem unwilling to concede
some of these points on cruel and
unusual and on the second amendment that
i've brought up
uh i think we have to distinguish
between
two kinds of originalism there's
the originalism that academics have come
up with
okay uh and academics have a decent
account
of uh academic originalists have
have come up with a decent account of
the second amendment
problems and how we can deal with them
uh and the cruel and unusual punishment
provision
and a whole bunch of other things uh
equality for women
uh as a you know significant matter
so the academic theory actually has a
certain amount of
credibility but then there's the
practice of originalism
by judges who say they are originalists
and that's sharply different from what
the academics say
and it's entirely inconsistent uh they
are originalists when
uh the results they come up with
fit their mostly conservative ideology
and then they depart from originalism
when
they haven't figured out how to
defend their conservative positions
in originalist terms the best example of
that incidentally is
affirmative action um uh there's
there's just no uh
no credible i should
the academics have a credible way of
defending or of attacking affirmative
action
uh uh on originalist grounds but
conservative judges haven't even
bothered to try
they just think that it's inconsistent
with some
fundamental principle of equality that
they're committed to
without trying to link that principle to
original
understandings okay this is good because
it adds a level of nuance when we hear
those who are not
particularly well educated on this bring
up this issue of original intent
in order to defend some of their
conservative ideals so when we talk
about constitutional originalism you're
pointing out
there is judicial constitutional
originalism
and then there is academic
constitutional originalism and that
these are two different things and
as you're putting forward the idea that
academic constitutional originalism
does deal with some of these apparent
contradictions maybe we could dig into
one of them like for example
on second amendment and the idea of what
arms referred to
hundreds of years ago versus the the
weapons available today
how would the academic originalists sort
of deal with that
so the academic account is actually
there are two versions of the academic
account
one is tied to
what we mostly think about these days
and
it is you say
you have to think about the kinds of
weapons that people had in mind
that were understood to be covered by
the second amendment
right and when they
thought about and talked about the
weapons that were covered by the second
amendment
they referred to weapons that everybody
has access to
or in the current phrase weapons and
common use
and so now you translate that to the
current
circumstances and you ask what weapons
are in current use today
um so so weapons and current use then
were muskets and
things like that they're not in current
use now but
ordinary handguns are in current use um
on the other hand bazookas are not in
current use
so you're making an analogy in other
words you have to you have to think of
what was what would be analogous to
those weapons today
yeah okay exactly um so that's one way
of doing it
sure the other way is much more radical
and actually i think my own view is
uh more connected to what was actually
going on
um the original understanding on this
second view of the second amendment
was that it was a way of ensuring
that ordinary people would be able
to fight against
an overreaching government
uh they would be able to arm themselves
to protect themselves
not against criminals right but against
you know soldiers
um and given what the military has today
that would imply a very very high a
loose
standard for what it would mean for
exactly and
no no contemporary defender of the
second amendment except
people associated with you know these
michigan militia types
want to go there and so the judges
uh say well we don't you know they may
have had this original understanding
about
what was called the insurrectionist view
but
but that's not what we think the
original understanding was
uh and they do that precisely for this
sort of
um uh um instrumental reason
uh ends focused reasons
uh they don't want to say people have a
right to have bazookas or anti-tank
weapons
right now it seems like you could apply
a similar standard to this idea of cruel
and unusual punishments right where
where you would say well just because
there are things available now that
weren't available then and some of the
things that were done then have gone out
of style
we have to sort of evaluate what is
analogous at this time
right right and and here
in fact again the academic position
is yeah that's right and it might be
that in particular capital punishment
or life in prison without parole for
juveniles those
might be inconsistent with the
fundamental ideas that were understood
to be written into the cruel and unusual
punishment punishments clause and again
what judicial originalists do is they
abandon the originalism
and they say well look the text says
capital crimes so whatever
they thought cruel and unusual
punishment meant they
also thought capital punishment was
constitutionally permissible um and and
so again you see this inconsistency
between
the practice of conservative judges who
want to uphold capital punishment
and um originalism
as it might be coherently worked out
ab absolutely fascinating i think the
big takeaway is
no matter what you call your philosophy
there is still debate to be had in
figuring out exactly how
we define it and and different versions
of it
uh uh that's right i mean uh i think
the the again i'm an academic the
academic view of these debates
is that with relatively
minor exceptions um
whatever your theoretical position is
you're going to be able to fit your
current
political views into it
and that means that the theoretical
stuff really
really isn't doing any serious work
what's going on is you're a liberal or
you're conservative
and that's how you rule yes uh very well
described by
by behavioral economists in fact like
daniel kahneman
and and others who have talked a lot
about that type of uh
motivated reasoning which clearly exists
within the issue of of constitutional
scholarship as well
uh we've been speaking with mark tushnet
emeritus professor at harvard law school
uh professor it's been such a pleasure
speaking with you i so appreciate your
time
i enjoyed it and appreciate being on